it's a calling she often finds hard to
explain it comes from a deep desire to
defend her country in its waters
after visiting Senegal's naval
headquarters on a school field trip 16
you'll fetch up has made up her mind
she'll be joining the Navy it's a noble
cause protecting the ocean from
polluting vessels and saving people's
lives at sea even if it's dangerous I
want to be part of the mission the Navy
is on a drive to recruit more soldiers
at sea while piracy globally has dropped
the number of boats attacked in the Gulf
of Guinea has doubled in the last year
this has become the world's most
dangerous waters normally is it a major
transit route for cargo ships the shores
of Senegal are also rich in marine life
attracting illegal deep-sea fishing
vessels that are polluting the seafloor
ninety percent of the world's trade
happens on water we need to protect the
oceans to protect our economies and the
trade most attacks are taking place off
the coast of Nigeria in Angola - oil
exporting countries the attackers are
gangs often made up of poor fishermen
frustrated and seeing this wealth they
have no access to taken away from their
Shores
Senegal discovered 50 trillion cubic
feet of natural gas and a billion
barrels of oil it has just allocated
exploitation rights to multinationals
the drilling hasn't started but there's
this expectation that this newfound
wealth will be equally redistributed
among all Senegalese especially among
the fishermen communities who have
suffered from illegal fishing on these
waters they say the ocean is a precious
resource that needs to be protected
while the Trump administration says it's
pulling back US troops in Africa in
March the US Navy organized its largest
naval games in Africa and the Gulf of
Guinea with 3,000 troops 33 countries
including Senegal there are no physical
boundaries on our territorial waters and
so to protect us
we need manpower and soldiers willing to
take action and neutralize the enemy
when needed and so this will require new
strategy for Senegal and the region with
fresh recruits willing to take risks
needed to protect the ocean and it's
untapped well Nicholas Hawk al Jazeera
at Dakar